it is wild 94 won the bay's party
station the bootleg cat show I'm sitting
down in front of the single greatest pro
wrestling advocate manager of all time
Paul Heyman man I must say it is an
honor truly an honor you where you feel
that we thank you for everything
yeah man yo I always I always tell my
kids to see my son is obviously a huge
wrestling fan and every Monday we watch
Raw
actually we have fools so we watch it on
Tuesday
so let's see at school in the morning
right so we always want you to keep them
up yeah we don't keep going yeah so
Tuesday we wash it and but you don't
deprive him of watching this of course
not you just schedule it appropriation I
really watch raw every week just to
watch your promos man they're incredible
let's talk about WrestleMania 31
obviously you and Brock have been
connected for a very long time
he is the one behind 21 and one last
year was one of the most memorable
moments as a wrestling fan I can
remember when he beat Undertaker what is
the atmosphere like now compared to last
year how is it different more visceral
last year when knew we were going to
shock the world and bring tears to the
eyes of children and this year I think
we are ready for the fallout of exactly
how visceral of beating Brock Lesnar is
gonna lay down on Roman reigns and how
people are gonna sit there and say
that's not very family-friendly Brock
Lesnar just really put [__]
how many suplexes can we expect how many
suplex repeats are we gonna hear from
you if you had to make a bold prediction
I don't know what's it sixteen against
Cena or sixteen ago let's go for
seventeen can we go up step I don't know
this is gonna be silly baby brother's
just gonna cut him off at the knees and
take him down and ride him bitch-slap
them straight into the man he was
there's lots of different game plans as
to how to humiliate another man and
impose your will on him and Brock Lesnar
will make that decision on Sunday
exactly how he's going to emasculate
Roman reigns he also just announced the
Sports Center was a couple days ago that
he's resounded with nevi w/e which
correct is good news for you I would
presume - I want to ask you
annex he's been getting so much love
lately if you had to pick someone who's
currently on the NXT roster to be a Paul
Heyman guy who would you think why do
you limit me to for him and die why kid
could be a Paul Heyman girl true because
there's a the Divas division amazing
it's amazing
yes it's a why okay so if you had to
pick a Paul Heyman person a bull with in
NXT if Ben said hey Paul I want you to
bring somebody up
make the call who am i bringing up to be
a Paul Heyman guy the entire roster the
entire roster strength in numbers this
is true and the great foothold into the
future that is a political answer can I
get one or two though could you give me
one or two your specifically I'm gonna
say I love Sami Zayn and I love Finn
Balor I don't disagree with either of
those assessments and I mean Sasha back
I mean first round draft pick 100% sure
of it
Charlotte's amazing words right now
yes yes they got a lot of a lot of a lot
of potential speaking of potential there
was research on Owens Kevin Owens is
amazing first-round draft pick in dean
there was a recent is yes he's not
personally knock somebody you know I
went to a house show in Tampa
couple months ago and I forget the guys
name he had a really bad gimmick though
hey has it changed yet
I really don't remember the guys name he
had like really thick sideburns and it
was like doing the corny rocker so he's
not around right now he's I don't ever
see him on the actual so now right now
NXT solid front to back it's an entire
roster first round draft but upset so
when I sit there and I say to you the
whole roster not being truthful strength
in numbers
and a foothold into the future straight
up there was a interview obviously a lot
of people watched the stone-cold podcast
with Vince and he was asked about Cesaro
and of course Cesaro last year had a
great he had a lot of momentum out out
of Wrestlemania he won the Andre the
Giant memorial trophy and then became a
Paul Heyman guy Vince said that like he
thought something was kind of missing
this is our as to why he didn't maybe
you know go to that next level cuz a lot
of people are always chanting Cesaro is
has such a huge talent which he is what
do you think he's missing why do you
think he's I didn't say Cesaro is
missing the Internet's that Spencer is I
mean in your appliance why is it that
Xaro hasn't may be broken out into a
potential that a lot being connected
with Vince McMahon you that's true
that's straight up that's that's a
straight-up answer what did you expect
nothing else nothing else besides your
candy turn no don't candy coat anything
don't count again
straight up yeah don't candy coat
anything CM Punk out did you talk about
often as you'd like to beautiful okay
all right I'll take that I want to kind
of go back to as often as he needs and
as little as he likes okay I want to go
back to when ECW came I mean obviously I
think when you look back and you watch
the documentaries it's pretty apparent
in WWE's success really you had a lot to
do with that because they kind of karma
copied a lot of what you see WI was
doing and form their version of that to
become the Attitude Era but when ECW
kind of came back with WWE in the early
2000s it sucked
it did suck why do you think it sucked
because it wasn't in CW anyway it was
WWE's version of ECW and no one wanted
to see if you could go back and do
something I can't go back never go back
hey if your aunt had balls she'd be your
uncle she doesn't so she's not this is
true there I deal in absolutes I don't
deal with hips what are you looking
forward to match wise besides obviously
uh Roman reigns and Brock Lesnar what is
the match that you are here comes an
answer that you can accuse me of being
diplomatic and pull it all of them so
I'll tell you but I'll tell you okay
because they're all on the four-wheel so
we're following everyone we're out there
in the main event
damn right I'm looking forward to seeing
what goes on before us so that by the
end of the night the only thing that
matters and the only thing you're gonna
remember there any people talk about
WrestleMania Thirds they talk about the
streak ending that's all they talk about
anything else right you want to steal
the show again we want to cement Brock
Lesnar's legacy into this show and brand
this show another moment that people say
should father give that to another unit
so all of them because they're our
very nice you're obviously one of the
greatest minds in wrestling history how
do you feel about Undertaker not being
on TV in the bill go and I agree with
you you like it yes to pay the same and
Bray's done a great job I didn't say I
didn't have any criticism for Alliance
job what you're the trainer is going to
look like everybody wants to know how's
he gonna react
what's he gonna be like for him to walk
out with that one on is going will you
still have the same swagger but we still
have the same confidence still have the
same or will the other members of the
audience besides the person for whom I'm
speaking at this moment which is Joe
public right Joe WB universe how will
the other 79 thousand people in the
Stadium want to see it oh those answers
get the network do what you gotta do but
if you want to know we make you pay to
see I agree with what has been your
favorite raw moment that you've had
there's been so many man like you've
really I mean I can't remember the last
time a manager's closed out a Monday
Night Raw with the promo I mean you're
like you know you're a lot of people a
lot of my friends specifically tuned in
to offer for your mic work what's been
like over the last year or so like a
moment that stood out were you like I
said my my favorite performance was the
one in Chicago before last year's
WrestleMania when I came out to see him
together because it was a challenge
never to raise my voice because the
audience was so pissed that it wasn't
even coming out I've watched that I've
arrived was pissed and they were there
to disrupt the show they were there to
hijack the show I made it my mission to
back him down and I back today yeah and
I never had to raise my voice to do it
and the energy in that room is just
so enormous that you're just
automatically ready to raise your voice
and even when you speak you're ready to
speak like this and it's not right the
whole object was to lure them in and to
get them to listen to me and to simply
speak I enjoyed that
I enjoyed the promo the day after
WrestleMania
SummerSlam and I'm really super I love
that man and the fact that you had a kid
like you hit it like down like the
perfect amount of times and everything
it's so precise I got like I'm waiting
for you to like screw up man like you
don't ever fall I'm never gonna give you
that it's ever happens but so my
favorite promo is the one I'm gonna cut
this Monday after Russell I can't wait
for that yeah your guy right here next
to you amy-jo we're in a Macho Man
t-shirt yes he is do you know he's dead
right
yes I just wanted to make sure people
know some people are coming like coming
to the Hall of Fame not knowing with
they're gonna be very surprised now my
friend here is a super-duper mark he is
but there are people who wanna make sure
you do know just so you know if you came
for Macho Man you're not gonna see him
not around not here to take the award
that was besides punk and and Brock
you've had a few other people you've
been advocates for over the last three
years
who did you enjoy working with the most
besides those two guys in what way
because they were placed in a situation
where they could not be the spotlight as
a Paul Heyman guy Cesaro
I feel Pete the moment he introduced me
as his advocate
and I thought that was a little
premature I thought I I really wanted to
see him kind of go the baby-faced route
after WrestleMania last run I think we
went downhill from there plus he had a
point to me and rewarding the bragging
rights of Brock rossler's conquering the
street so that was bad for Cesaro Curtis
axle and Ryback had to be supporting
players in the CM Punk versus Paul
Heyman field right because that had so
much equity in it there was no way to
justify Curtis axel arrived back beneath
the spotlight Travis to personal issue
was between the end punk and people pay
to see personal issues so on the on the
flip side for them they didn't get a
chance to be spotlighted they just got a
chance to be a supporting player that
sucks woman so it wasn't a career
opportunity to be a Polish Oh God CM
Punk before it was because he was the
WWE Champion and you added so much to
that and now he has his rabbi his best
friends of the past it was amazing in
guiding him and taking him down a very
obviously the fact Brock doesn't have to
talk right you know who you could help
out Roman reigns because we I think I
think you have the other sunlight
Zeppelin death and I'm late Roman reigns
a huge fan of course of Roman reigns I
think he is dramatically
underappreciated
he's improved a lot he nor the immensely
and fast - yeah - fast he's on the fast
track for sure you know and I think the
audience is very unappreciative the
world
who's the most underrated wrestler on
the roster right Brock Lesnar all right
I don't think he gets the credit to be
deserves really really he's he's tough
he's I mean a lot of people say John
Cena is the face with Brock my ministry
question is is the top here greatest
wrestler of all time
quick see I disagree
good question
greatest in-ring performer ever saw -
disagree what is there anything that
Shawn Michaels does and Brock Lesnar
are there things that brought Lesnar
Candice's okay that's Shawn Michaels
can't do this is putting brocco bomb
Shawn most under rated under a prefix a
this keeping it funky Brock's presence
on the mic might not be up to where
Shawn Michaels or a macho man I mean and
that's just yeah we're talking about in
the ring is your right hand ring
performer
Paul Heyman just checked me successfully
wrestling and Brock doesn't need to
speak on the morning he does not that's
what he has me for this is prime Brock
Jews beautiful right I just got checked
back home the most underappreciated the
most underrated recipe ever and now
actually then now and forever
when stone cold got let go from WCW and
you let him come to ECW cut those promos
which were amazing what was going
through your head because I feel like
that was like I feel like that kind of
thing is missing to wear a obviously now
it's W is really the only game in town
that matters but my fault
but there's not a lot of people that
jump out take chances on people without
there being any any money in the pot
already hate that a shame ya know it
really is but what we what what your
what we was going to your mind when I
know Steve when I manage them in WCW for
as far the dangerous ones and if you go
back to WCW magazine and you read an
article that I wrote in a danger zone
column in 1992 beginning of 1992 I said
within the next ten years Steve Austin
will be the number one star in this
industry
all we saw it in and it's not that I
could see things that other people
didn't see it said I saw things that
other people weren't willing to see how
does Steve Austin walk in a room and if
you're not if you're not feeling that
ain't paying attention right that's real
well look Paul Heyman I'm a Paul Heyman
guy man I really appreciate everything
you do for the business you you make raw
exciting for me and for a lot of adults
I mean that it's really what I look
forward to I look forward to especially
Monday Night Raw I will look forward to
whatever the outcome is and what you
want to learn this is what's gonna
happen
Brock Lesnar is gonna destroy Roman
reigns limb from limb and he will be
holding the belt Monday oh absolutely
I don't see them you know what I mean
I'd like to see him go on I mean out to
destroy reigns and then Seth Rollins
cash in and then he beats that beats the
hell out of sent along as well and then
you know then there's really no argument
okay we got to see that come get ladies
attention his name is Paul Heyman name
is Paul him and he's the man I am the
man that's what oh thank you